It is
time for
the House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy,
to make good on promises
made to Republican hardliners
who initially opposed his nomina
His election after a storied fiv
15 ballot, four or five,
came with a list of concessions
made to GOP holdouts
in exchange for their support.
Now, some of those deals
are going into effect,
and let's talk about it now with
senior political analyst, anchor
senior political analyst John Av
He's here with me now. So how ar
Good morning to you.
How are these concessions playin
All right.
Well, let's first of all, rememb
these are the core holdouts, the
so holdouts, vast
majority election deniers.
These are the folks who took the
fight for Kevin McCarthy.
Back to standard.
We haven't seen since
before the Civil War.
Already
we're seeing rewards
coming to these folks. Right.
So six members,
these holdout groups
getting plum positions
on the appropriations committee,
including Andrew Clyde.
Describe January six
as a tourism day at the Capitol
and Financial Services Committee
Very powerful committees.
But let's also take a look
at the key concessions.
These are just some of them.
This is the deals
that Kevin McCarthy made
to finally get the votes across.
So, first of all,
any member can call a motion
to vacate the speaker's chair.
Freedom Caucus
representatives,
many of whom are on that page,
increase representation
on key committees.
This is the debt ceiling
we've been talking so much about
This is a sign of coming attract
we're going to have on
a collision course.
Discretionary spending
at 22 levels, weapon
invest committee
to investigate the weaponization
of the federal government.
And of course, 72 hours
to review bills
before they come to the floor,
which sounds common.
Sense but can gum up the works.
I got to ask you about this
from a prominent Republican.
I got this note that says farmer
in this Clyde and cloud
were appointed
to the Appropriations Committee.
These guys were rewarded
for bad behavior
during the speaker's vote.
This is a stunning
and a part of a handshake deal
between the holdouts.
I won't use the word that they u
He said nuts and McCarthy,
nuts and McCarthy,
which they will never admit to p
What do you think about that?
Do you believe that's true?
Well, here's the evidence that i
You're talking to a source
in the Republican conference
who's saying this is happening.
It is already happening.
We've got to say
the committee assignments aren't
even fully been doled out yet.
But to see folks
who put Kevin McCarthy in the co
really through that kind of chao
get rewarded with appropriations
It's a very big deal.
What I also wanted to
do this as sort of a bonus is
look at where
independent voters
say what the Republicans in Cong
should be focusing on.
Remember, independent voters,
they're the plurality
of American politics.
They're the folks who actually
swung towards Democrats this cyc
So Republicans
got to keep their wishes in mind
Interestingly,
now, 71% of independents
say this new CBS poll,
they want Republicans in the Hou
to work with Biden's and Dems
to enact policies
that everyone can agree on. Righ
Come together.
By the way, incidentally,
they say the same thing about De
in the Senate.
They say, 67% say protecting
Social Security.
65% of independents say support
aid to Ukraine. Far from a done
59% say reducing crime.
Those are high numbers.
Take a look at the border.
Only 25% say investigating Hunte
Only 20% say restricting abortio
And only 10% of independent vote
say Republicans in the House
should focus on loyalty to Donal
So there's a disconnect there
that goes to the heart
of their political.
John Avlon, thank you very much.